Anabelle creation is directed by David F
Sandberg and is the prequel to Annabelle
which was a prequel to the conjuring and
this movie is a copy Annabelle doll and
its origins how it was created
how it became possessed and the horror
that it inflicted on an orphanage a
dividend Sandburg directed lights out a
horror film that I thought was pretty
inventive and very clever
it took one idea and got the most out of
it it was actually pretty enjoyable and
want to stand out horror movies of last
year so I went into this movie with some
expectations I was like okay and then we
g2 surprised me as well both of these
films feature Lulu Wilson both of them
are prequels to a horror film that
wasn't very well received and both of
them are light years better than their
predecessor everything in the cosmos
that has ever happened in the
entertainment world points to a prequel
of a prequel being surprisingly
Annabelle creation is quite a bit of fun
it's a very enjoyable and entertaining
Lee made horror film with quite a bit of
good scares we followed two young girls
in this film Janice and Linda are their
best friends and they're at this
orphanage and throughout the film their
friendship is tested because there's a
presence there that's trying to rip them
apart that's trying to separate them and
that aspect of the movie gave it more
depth than I thought it was going to
have because I actually found myself
caring about these two girls and what
their future could be they both have
wishes about how they would love to be
adopted by the same parents and have a
family together and live together and
they constantly talk about their wishes
for the future so it's not always bump
in the night scares you do have
characters in this film that are set up
that you can actually root for and care
for and so when things start to get more
serious and more sinister towards the
third act
I felt invested I wasn't just watching a
movie with a lot of good scares that
were set up well I actually cared about
the characters which trust me major
surprise really I mean going into this
movie I'm
like walking out of it it was like I was
just breathing new air I felt like okay
with Ouija two and now with Annabelle
creation I really hope that Studios who
are making horror films mainstream
horror not just indie horror but
mainstream horror realize that they can
actually make good movies with good
filmmakers who would have thought I mean
who really would have thought good
filmmakers make good movies what I
surprised
Sandburg utilizes the things that are
most important in a horror film to build
scares sound design cinematography those
two things are imperative to building
suspense and the sound design and
cinematography are immaculate this movie
sounds so good and it looks so good it's
also refreshingly unpretentious it's
just a fun haunted house ride from
beginning to end a lot of fun scares
some good character and not much else I
think when Sandburg took on the prequel
to a prequel that a lot of people called
a cash grab and a lot of people were
looking at this movie just like really
people looked at the first antebellum or
like really but he's gone and made a
horror film that's just a blast it's
just fun it's entertaining it's an
old-fashioned horror movie that you can
watch from beginning to end get a little
bit on the edge of your seat and enjoy
the ride
where I would normally think that a back
story for the Annabelle doll wouldn't be
necessary we're now in a world where
every major studio wants to have a
universe of some kind and we now have a
conjuring universe that's just it's it's
a thing okay we have conjuring conjuring
- Annabelle we're going to get the nun
it's a thing we have to accept it with
this film there is actually some lore
added to it and it ties in to the first
in a very cool way and the preview
audience I saw it with bursted into
applause at that moment this movie is
surprisingly not bad at all as for flaws
I think the first half has far too many
jump scares there's a lot of building to
something and then a big loud noise
happens
then you're like okay that happened now
I feel I can breathe for a second
there's a lot of that kind of stuff and
sometimes I like my scares to be hinted
at Mike Flanagan does that very well
with his horror films he builds through
sound design has a lot of very subtle
edits and sometimes he'll just show you
things on the screen that startle you
but there's no music accompanying it
this film relies quite a bit on really
loud noises a lot towards the third act
it builds towards actual frightening
imagery with very subtle uses of gore
it's not overdone it's very much so the
way James Wan would helm a horror film
if there's going to be gore it's going
to be brief and subtle it's not going to
be like hey look at all this blood isn't
that horrifying because we know that's
not what it's like we're not scared
because you see blood in a horror movie
this movie subtle its atmospheric so
over reliance on jump scares for the
first half but beyond that this is a
really enjoyable horror film the young
actresses are great in the movie all the
performances are actually pretty strong
this is far better than this movie
really deserves to be and I'm excited to
see what else David F Sandberg does I'm
going to give Annabel creation of beads
plus guys thank you so much as always
for watching let me know we think of the
film if you get a chance to see it and
as always if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]